welcome welcome everyone it's real
review time yeah favorite show on
YouTube welcome to me were you it's a
show where we explore and review the
latest memes of course for the
importance of history to document why is
my forehead not in this shot a few weeks
back on meme review we hadn't mean
called that Tide Pods meme and I'm sure
you're familiar with it now now that
it's got a literally mainstream media
attention because people actually ate
the Tide Pods you're not supposed to eat
the Tide Pods oh you're crazy the joke
was that you you were wanted to eat them
but you don't eat them don't eat the
Tide Pods guys I'm very serious right
now as you can tell on my tone of voice
and facial expression don't need to type
odds what are you crazy
oh my god you could die don't eat I'd
putt you ruined the mean you're ruining
me what do you want me to say good job
now that the tide pond meme is dead weed
though have a substitute don't worry so
don't be too sad we have substitute me
and of course I am talking about the far
superior meme over tight bond wishes
isopod meme that's right have you heard
of isopods amazing size 55 centimeters
isopods what do you know about them well
number one there are crust crust
Achaeans
not an insect crustacean they breathe
through gills and listen to this they
don't urinate how crazy is that
dude these peoples going captured a nice
upon fun may I even say beloved into the
estrus hot what is it I have not
it's like what a wonderful name for a
nicer POTUS I sure wish I had a nicer
pod pets now don't worry
these can live online for a couple hours
and they can literally go years without
eating now this might seem cruel but
they did return venue to water now of
course we don't want to eat the ice
apart we just want to befriend them who
doesn't want a nicer part friend I would
never say no if you're a nice upon
watching right now look how cute they
are
tickle tickle ah that's an enemy girl in
her eyes upon pet that's the door look
how much that cat is having a good time
with this ice apart friend oh look
another anime girl with her eyes upon I
sure am jealous for everyone he is
having an isopod here their head they're
having a little tea party oh look how
cute look how happy she oh that she's
happy with her eyes apart as the pod
also can be quite fierce if they want to
here's footage of isopods capturing a
shark
they protect but they also attack but
when its are you support hours that's
when it gets real can I get an iced
apart ours in the chat pod ours
[Music]
it's I support our everybody oh yeah
that's really cool now I know it's your
warning where are the Z's come from well
they are technically bottom dwellers but
I do also think they come from the old
game halo on Xbox
[Music]
[ __ ] the type on me was horrible meme
that led to a lot of people suffering in
pain now I feel like we can do something
positive with a pod meme the isopod mean
can really take off and bring happiness
and joy on the earth and give life
meaning to some people as myself for
example I will rate the isopod meme a
solid system 5 6 & a 5 everybody the ice
apart six point six because they're so
damn cute and I just can't have six
point eight and that's final
isopod let's see where it goes is it
isopod hour yet they just finished it
just finished next this mean if blowing
up can we get a siren of meme attack
[Music]
I don't know what this name is called
basically having as some sort of Giants
attacking versus something very small
here you have seniors versus hot
freshmen girl here you have the
boogeyman versus my foot hanging off the
vent here you have me versus unfinished
water bottle by my bed at through here
yeah
there's also me my cousin and her bridge
we have normies and this meme in two
weeks pretty much pretty much minecraft
invite from Kevin versus me doing
homework on a school night Wow it's hard
to resist her invite of Minecraft from
Kevin my uncle after a few drinks my
seven-year-old me versus my phone on
full brightness at 1:00 a.m. Wow
search power me and just women which
reminds me this meme is really just a me
respecting women mean but they just
changed it with Giants it still works
because there's so many video there's so
many pictures to go from and there's so
many relatable moments such as me and my
pencil that I just dropped incredible
FBI employee
my laptop's camera the one to establish
a worldwide communist regime in which I
am Supreme Leader and take all the funds
for the government thus everyone is
equal in the money they have but nobody
has enough money to form a resistance
and plot a government takeover versus my
sanity me versus the soda that someone
left this meme format dead memes
Instagram pretty much kid who works kid
whose dad worked for Microsoft my xbox
live account you don't want to mess with
someone that knows the dead that works
for X fix my headache versus ibuprofen
people spamming this meme format my
enjoyment of this mean
well this is a very adaptability
bubblebeam I don't it's it's so fresh
that I don't even know its name I'm
gonna immediately give it to extra bonus
points for being fresh
oh no the bonus points have been lost
this meme is already dying give it
enough five this meme gets a five
next mean place thank you let's move on
it's time for bonus
[Music]
good time and good luck for your good
fortune must be with you the voters mean
for this week is connect for that
connect for me it basically started with
the artwork of this classic connect for
game where they're just having such a
great time and people just started to
photoshop it it's really that's it
that's it here we have a connect one
that's a tricky one we have a connect
one that one game we have a connect
strap which is who does that come on you
gotta live life on the edge
we have Connecticut and his face is
Connecticut that's great that's a great
one I enjoy that game not how creative
you can make Kinect child oh it's a
reverse meme excellent excellent
we have connect the evidence of election
rigging we have bit connect for the
classic we have connect loss really the
classic meme that somehow doesn't die
net yes of course that is great to play
I love net the neck oh wow that's also a
very exciting help I glued my hands to
my face can you stop Thanks good meme
cone I'm not playing cone that's awesome
hilarious pepperoni
look at that pepperoni that's a very
funny pepperoni and of course my
personal favorite Kinect crab it's
tricky
gonna rate the for Kinect I started the
Papa Papa Papa Papa Papa Papa five point
seven point five everybody
mean review hope you guys enjoyed liebe
if you enjoyed and as always remember to
have a great smile